i think there's a there's a kind of a
misconception that
bitcoin is completely anonymous it's
really pseudo-anonymous
um if a a state actor or even a big
corporation wants to find out
um who transferred bitcoin to whom um it
can be done
um the it's harder than just looking at
someone's
visa or bank account um but i think
there are new technologies
built on top of bitcoin like the
lightning network that
for very small amounts will keep it
almost like cash where it'll be much
harder it won't be worth the
uh the uh the effort
all right i'm dave rubin we are on
location in miami i am with
alex lloyd co-author of the little
bitcoin book why bitcoin matters for
your freedom
finances and future we're obviously in
the right city for that so
lloyd why does it matter you know we um
i this we came at this book from a human
rights perspective
one of my co-authors alex glassteen is
the chief strategy officer of the human
rights foundation
and there were a lot of books out there
about the technical nature and the
financial nature
of why bitcoin is important this one
really gives more a socio-political
aspect
why everyday people are going to bitcoin
is going to be important to them
and that's kind of the angle we took so
we talked about this a little bit at
dinner last night i mean basically
you think bitcoin will will sort of free
people
as these systems around us kind of go
down is that
fair to say um i think what it is it's
it's a
democratization of capital if you think
of the history of how
um individuals got more power in the
world it started with democracy there's
a lot of steps here but
democracy has a political system i think
you know another step that you might
think of is
freedom of speech in the internet which
let anybody be a publisher and a creator
and i think bitcoin is the next step
which is people um
can be their own banks and have their
own individual freedom um
whereas the internet in a way was a way
to let any two people exchange
ideas and information and bitcoin is
going to be a way that any two people
can
exchange value and that's
a big part of this book so since most of
my audience is pretty tech savvy but not
everybody
for the person that's watching this
right now that has no bitcoin they've
heard the word bitcoin
they're like what the hell is bitcoin
it's not backed by anything what is this
thing
give me give me the q a portion of this
because you guys end this chapter six is
all a q a
about sort of the basics i i think if
you think of um
as americans a lot of people don't
understand the privilege we have in
terms of the amount of
um resources financial resources banks
credit card apple pay all these systems
that you know uh
paypal that let us exchange value
between people but
um billions of people across the world
don't have any such technology they
probably will never have a bank account
and bitcoin is a way for them to in a
way be their own bank
and in an unstoppable way exchange value
with anybody across the whole world
and i think that's the the message that
um that that really makes bitcoin not
this crazy
trading scheme or you know you know a
lot of um
people think it's just like a ponzi
scheme but this is if you think about it
it's a
way for people billions of people to
exchange
uh and store value without having any
government or company involved in it and
that's a very powerful idea
what about the other cryptos where do
they fit into this the other coin
um this book is really focused on
bitcoin i think there's a place for a
lot of other types of technology and
bitcoin is an evolving thing there's
going to be other
things that graft onto it like the
lightning network so
they'll be you'll be able to do millions
or billions of transactions a day
but bitcoin in and of itself is really
the the the
preeminent way to store value in
exchange it was really designed in an
amazing
amazingly start smart way and the book
goes into why it's different from
um any previous type of money can you
explain the difference between
why you would use bitcoin to store
versus necessarily using it as
what you're buying with basically all
the time well i think that as it stands
now bitcoin is probably not the best way
to buy things just because
there's millions of other uh easier ways
to exchange value if you're in
in the united states or europe or um you
know a
company that has a banking system but um
what we have seen is
um there are uh human rights advocates
throughout
the world who live in dictatorships and
um
they have no way of safely soaring
anything that they create in terms of
value
and if they store cash under their
mattress that can get taken
if they have money in their bank account
that could get taken by the
government by fiat and but what's even
worse a lot of countries have a
hyperinflation so that's just the
insidious way of stealing money from
people
without them really noticing it in the
short term
that's kind of where we're going right
now it's possible um and that's
that's maybe a bigger case for bitcoin
but bitcoin is the first way
first time that people um the human
rights foundation does
um give grants to human rights advocates
uh throughout the world and before it
was a multi-step process that took days
and
was fraught with um you know apparel in
terms of getting them
capital and now through bitcoin there's
really a simple way that
we can send uh people capital
and they can use it and store it in a
safe way and that's really never been
possible right so basically human rights
foundation you can find people that are
doing good work in some country trying
to
free people whatever whatever it is and
then you can send them bitcoin and that
way whatever work they're doing that the
government is not
probably thrilled with it's theirs and
the government technically doesn't even
know about it
exactly should we be talking about that
right now or uh should we like what the
government's not going about
like i think there's a there's a kind of
a misconception that
bitcoin is completely anonymous it's
really pseudo-anonymous
um if a state actor or even a big
corporation wants to find out um
who transferred bitcoin to whom um it
can be done
um the it's harder than just looking at
someone's visa or bank account
um but i think there are new
technologies built on top of bitcoin
like the lightning network that for very
small amounts will keep it
almost like cash where it'll be much
harder it won't be worth the um the
uh the effort to track how's this all
connected to just decentralizing
everything you know i mean you know the
world i'm in where everybody's worried
that if you put a video up
that youtube doesn't like you're going
down or if you put a tweet up that
twitter doesn't like they're gonna
get rid of you just the general like
decentralization i think this was the
proof
the first technology really proved it
could work and
um the designer or inventor of bitcoin
was really smart in terms of creating
um an amazing incentive uh network where
uh hundreds of millions of dollars has
been invested in
um the blockchain technology and the the
mining around it
without really any investment from
government or
venture capital can you give me mining
101 for people that don't get it at all
um bitcoin is all about proving that
what's in the
public ledger uh is accurate and
uh there's two parts of that one is
basically proving that
having thousands of independent
computers
and people running those computers check
to see that that ledger is correct
and then the other is finding new
bitcoin and that's
proving the work that you did enables um
the incentive structure to be set up so
that um
bitcoin can be created right what about
when uh
elon musk is like i'm into it and it
goes like this and then he's like i'm
not into it and it goes like this and
then that gets people
all freaked out i feel like it's you
know he's
having fun he might he's a very smart
guy he's created some really
incredible technologies um but he's also
someone who probably likes to troll a
lot on
um do you think on twitter and um he
also runs a
company that is um you know
very focused on green which is tesla and
you know i'm sure he got pushed back
saying bitcoin is in green which i i
think it is because a lot of the
uh a majority seventy percent of the
bitcoin is mined from renewable
sources because people are really
looking for the cheapest energy when
they mine a bitcoin and that's typically
renewable stuff
right but you know can you power it by
volcanoes isn't that what the
president of el salvador you will see i
hope it was literally what he's trying
to do like it seemed like a joke well if
you think about where
um bitcoin mining takes place it needs a
power source and if you create a huge
um solar cell in the middle of the uh
sahara desert
it's not really valuable energy because
you have to then ship that energy
right right to a city but if you created
a huge green
solar um plant in the middle of the
sahara desert and your output was
new bitcoin you that might be a a
financially viable situation
because you can just email out the new
bitcoin that you create and the output
is not a huge
cable pumping power it's just some
numbers
right for the somebody watching this
that's like all right
i didn't know much about it before i got
some basics here uh where where do they
start with all this do you want them to
i mean you send them to a wallet to
start like where do you exchange where
do you sell people
there's a lot of different ways and i
think the um
everybody is going to have a different
approach you can go to to like
essentially
uh you know stored wallet like coinbase
you can also
have an app on your phone where you
store stuff um you could have a
usb stick where you store stuff and i
think the
the major difference and maybe a lot of
people don't wrap their head around is
that you're your own bank so
that gives you a lot of freedom but then
it gives you some responsibilities
because
you know you don't you have to be the
person who
creates the wall around your privacy and
you have responsibilities when you get
that freedom
so that stick that i have in a safe the
password and all that i can't lose that
right you can't lose the key to this
thing
and you don't you don't want to post
your password don't post it don't have
it on the back of your
computer written there and then you take
a selfie and then everybody can see it
because then the bitcoin is gone i'm
gonna have to scribble that down here uh
all right i want to talk to you about
one other thing which is
that you basically were the were the
first big guy
in locals you you helped us put this
whole thing together and connected us
with
a ton of investors you opened up a
million doors for us
so i guess my question is what what did
you see
in what we were doing because you know
we talked to a lot of people at the
beginning a lot of people said it's a
good idea but
you know could be a little dangerous and
freeing people
and all that it made you know some
people scared but you were like well i
have to admit the
reason i took a meeting with you is
because i was a fan of your work
so i like the way you think and i was
like well i mean how
bad can it be i can meet this guy and
it'll be interesting conversation but
then what you described it in terms of
like giving power back to the creator
um and having a system where it's
i think unfortunately a lot of times um
in our society there's
big tech companies that have gotten a
little bit too much power and i really
liked your kind of
david versus google goliath approach to
things
and you know when i make a decision to
invest in a company it's really about
the team and your team with the soft
was really impressive and the technology
um
we're building was right on what i
thought could work and then it's proven
really to be
true and i've seen so many creators
thrive on your platform
you know they can quit their day job and
just be on on locals and
have an amazing life and just continue
to create and that's impossible on other
platforms so
you know i i think i've been proven
right that you know investing in you and
your team has been a really good thing
what's the funnest part of doing this
like watching these companies grow and
you know
you've had some nice wins i love
entrepreneurs yeah i think they're all a
little bit crazy they take these crazy
risks and it's really amazing to see it
pay off
um they you know they uh no same person
wants to be an entrepreneur but it's
that good kind of crazy like
you know taking on these intractable
problems and and building something
um and to me that's the most fun it's
the human aspect and
you know i'm kind of a computer geek i
love all the the technology aspects of
it
i mean i i'm a science fiction fan and i
love the idea of like
kind of seeing how sci-fi will play out
in the real world and you know what are
the trends that are going to work on
uh have impact on society we're
basically in a dystopian future right
now sometimes you know i think we live
in a simulation because this
craziest stuff is happening so my last
question for you
we're in miami you moved to miami so
yeah you're a case of
you lived in san francisco how long did
you live in every 20 years yeah 23 years
you just moved here in the last year
beautiful wife beautiful kids thriving
here
you think i'm nuts we're not leaving yet
um you know take your time and miami
will still be here but you know
definitely move here before your ipo
true wisdom from a great man and a great
investor alex lloyd thanks a lot
thank you nice if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about tech instead of non-stop yelling
check out our tech playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification
bell